seit tagen berichten wir über
gütersloher die teststationen für corona
sind komplett überlaufen die menschen
haben angst dass ich jetzt nicht mehr in
ihren urlaub fahren können denn nur wer
ein negatives testergebnis hat kann auch
weg aus nrw michael engelberg ist jetzt
für uns bei einer krone teststation
drive-in michael wie sieht das ganze aus
wie läuft das ganze ab ja also wir sind
hier in einem alten hubschrauber hangar
in gütersloh von den militärischen
streitkräften und es geht hier wie folgt
der festigen kann dass man eben einmal
zeigen ganz hinten wo die autos stehen
werden die daten der leute erfasst die
kommen dann hier vor gefahren und dann
können wir gerade in dem roten auto
sehen dass die soldaten jetzt den
abstrich machen quasi mit dem stäbchen
in den rachen gehen und dann dieses
stäbchen in eine weiße box schmeißen so
und das ganze läuft dann wie folgt die
leute können dann anhand dieses zettels
wenn sie sich die korona app
heruntergeladen haben das ganze wird mit
einem barcode versehen die persönlichen
angaben und dann können die auf das
testergebnis warten das wird ihnen dann
angezeigt und neben ihr steht der
punkten feuerwehr pressesprecher oliver
eichstätt vom feuerwehrverband gütersloh
sie sind ja maßgeblich mit der feuerwehr
und der bundeswehr und den anderen
hilfsorganisationen hier im einsatz und
sie haben neueste zahlen wie viele leute
hier schon getestet wurden und wie das
angenommen wird ja richtig ich kann
ihnen sagen dass wir gestern an den
sechs standorten 2880 tests durchgeführt
haben und wir haben 1200 tests hier an
diesem standort durchgeführt
wie geht es dann weiter die leute sind
werden dann hier getestet und
irgendjemand muss das ganze jahr
auswerten wo kommen die hin und wie
lange dauert das dann eventuell wenn ich
mit dieser app agiere bis ich mein
ergebnis habe das ist ja für leute die
hier in den urlaub wollen extremst
wichtig wie sie schon sagten eben sind
wir jetzt auch bemüht aufgrund dieses
zeitfensters 48 stunden wir
transportieren dreimal täglich die tests
von hier nach köln das geschieht unter
see gewonnen das sonderrecht und
wegerecht die fahren also mit blaulicht
dass die testergebnisse
schnellstmöglichst in köln sind wie
schnell das labor dort arbeitet die
haben natürlich auch enorm viel zu tun
kann ich ihnen nicht sagen die
testergebnisse wie sie schon eben
richtig sagten werden auf den app
angezeigt und dann hat man ein positives
ein negatives oder ein ergebnis wo
draufsteht
das ist noch in bearbeitung ist jetzt
sind ja ganz viele hilfsorganisationen
hier im einsatz die feuerwehr hat ja
primär auch andere aufgaben
nichtsdestotrotz wie motiviert sind die
kameraden auch der hilfskräfte in
verbindung mit der bundeswehr das ist ja
kein alltäglicher einsatz neben ihrer
normalen arbeit ganz viele sind ja
freiwillig und mussten ihren job dann
liegen lassen oder konnten nicht zur
arbeit weil sie hier für andere menschen
was tun
das ist richtig ich weiß aus
informationen aus allen bereichen hier
vor ort am flughafen aber auch aus der
technischen einsatzleitung der von der
kreisfeuerwehr geleitet wird das alle
motiviert sind und ich glaube auch für
den bürger des kreises gütersloh steht
das hier gar nicht außer frage dass wir
hier voll motiviert bis zum letzten test
alles geben was wir geben können also
gehört hier wird ganz wichtige arbeit
gemacht und noch mal die sind viele
dieser personen sind meistens nicht
sichtbar das sind die johanniter das ist
das bak das ist das technische hilfswerk
das ist die feuerwehr die freiwillige
feuerwehr die bundeswehr die tun hier
wirklich eine extrem wichtigen dienst
und man kann auch nur appellieren diese
leute zu unterstützen weil die sind für
andere da und das sagt man in diesen
schwierigen zeiten nicht vergessen die
sorgen nämlich dafür dass viele hier aus
dem kreis gütersloh tatsächlich die
möglichkeit haben in den urlaub zu
fahren
ein update möchte ich dann noch geben
die stadt münster hatte ja vor zwei
tagen gesagt dass personen die aus dem
kreis gütersloh aus dem kreis warendorf
kommen die stadt prinzipiell nur mit
maske betreten dürfen jetzt sind die
zahlen in dem kreis warendorf wirklich
sehr stark nach unten gegangen
dort wurde diese maßnahme für die
münsteraner innenstadt jetzt aufgehoben
und gestern wurden ja einheitliche
maßnahmen der gesundheitsminister aller
länder getroffen wie man das regelt dass
die leute hier in den urlaub kommen
es geht hier um stigmatisierung dass es
auch verschiedensten politischen ebenen
jetzt auch angesprochen worden
hier soll keiner stigmatisiert werden
jeder der einen negativen corona test
vorweisen kann soll in urlaub fahren und
das machen diese leute hier möglich wäre
ganz ganz herzlichen dank für diese
ausführlichen informationen aus
gütersloh